les rapides mots de soutien des manuels
macron lors de son allocution hier soir
n'ont pas rassuré les policiers bien au
contraire il souhaite que le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner
reviennent sur les propos qu'il a tenus
la semaine dernière et certains
souhaitent qu'il quitte le ministère
s'était un peu le sens de cette action
organisée à 13h30 devant l'hôtel de
police de versailles devant lequel je me
trouve une centaine de policiers du
département sont venus déposer au sol
leur brassard et leurs menottes
une manière d'affirmer leur opposition
notamment au gouvernement et françois
bersani secrétaire départemental adjoint
d'unité sgp police nous parle de ces
divergences de vues avec le gouvernement
reconfirmer par le président la
république ou le premier ministre à
l'égard des policiers
l'histoire du soupçons avérés ou du
doute raisonnable ou de faits établis
hors enquête judiciaire ou hors enquête
administrative ça ça n'est pas audible
pour pour nos collègues
on ne peut pas sanctionner quelqu'un à
savoir le suspendre systématiquement
s'il n'y a pas eu le commencement d'une
enquête judiciaire ou administrative
la sanction la suspension est une
sanction et on doit sanctionner sur des
faits établis et les faits établis en
france il souhaite abyss fois par la
justice donc judiciaire soit par la
justice administrative mais pas par des
vidéos récupérées sur youtube snapshot
pas par juste une déclaration de
victimes ou un témoin cette action
s'inscrit dans un mouvement de
contestation inédit jusqu'ici qui
illustre une crise de confiance entre la
police et le gouvernement
les déboires pour christophe castaner
avait a démarré dès octobre 2019 des
milliers de policiers avaient alors
entamé à paris une marche de la colère
pour exiger davantage de moyens et de
meilleures conditions de travail
fin 2019 la police avait craint pour son
régime de retraite donc un autre
mouvement de colère et puis plus
récemment durant la crise du coc vide
christophe castaner n'avait pas prévu le
port du masque et avait interdit le
droit de retrait or des chiffres d'avril
2020 montre que 1400 agents ont
contracté le qu'ovide donc aujourd'hui
avec les propos de christophe castaner
sur le racisme et d'autre part la
suppression de la prise de tête le
contrôle de tête durant les
interpellations et bien les policiers
ont entamé une série de démarches qui
ont commencé jeudi dernier
aujourd'hui il y avait également
d'autres actions simultanées à créteil
et dans le 93
et ce alors que les manifestations
contre le racisme dans la police ou les
violences policières se multiplient